hi i'm alex and this is my recipe for
chocolate strawberry cream puffs
[Music]
i love a good cream puff so this is a
recipe i actually made around
valentine's day because
it's kind of
like sexy
so we had done a couple of different
variations of cream puffs so i decided
to do just another variation of a cream
puff and i thought it was really cute to
do a strawberries and cream puff
but then take it a step further with a
chocolate strawberries and cream puff
a lot of plays on words here
so cream puffs can be a little bit
tricky to make but you break it down
it's really not too difficult
just takes
some time but it's valentine's day
well it's not a valentine's day but like
if it was valentine's day which is what
this recipe was intended for then you
should be willing to put in a little
extra time right so i started by making
this filling because it's going to need
time to kind of cool so this is like a
basic cream puff like a custardy filling
so this custard filling is egg yolks
heavy cream sugar
and cornstarch so once the custard
starts to thicken up we're going to add
in those chopped up strawberries and
then we're going to transfer that into a
bowl to cool i really wanted to use like
fresh strawberries because
i love fresh strawberries i just wanted
it to be like as close to like chocolate
covered strawberry would be just in kind
of a new way but if strawberries are out
of season or you just don't want to use
fresh strawberries you could also
replace that with strawberry jam and
incorporate strawberry into the filling
that way so now we're going to move on
to the
choux pastry
which
i've done a lot of times here and it's
always a workout
so prepare yourself
but again
you get your final workout in before you
go meet your date for valentine's day
you just got to get the method right
you're going to start in the heat
melting down your butter and your water
and once that's all liquefied you're
going to add in your flour and start to
mix so you're going to keep mixing this
on the heat until it's like a
homogenized dough and then we're going
to transfer that off and add in vanilla
and one egg at a time
so you want to add in the eggs slowly
off the heat because you don't want the
eggs to cook while you're incorporating
them into the dough it's got to take
some muscle power because you want to
make sure
every time you're incorporating an egg
that the dough is like fully mixed so
don't move too fast here just make sure
you're taking your time make sure you're
really incorporating the dough and
getting it as smooth as possible
and there you have it so we're going to
transfer that into a piping bag i
actually did it in a ziploc bag and
didn't even use a tip because it was a
little more user friendly because not
everybody has access to a piping bag and
piping tips so you're going to pipe that
dough onto your parchment-lined baking
sheet into kind of a round thing if you
want to you can take a finger and get it
a little wet and dab down the tips of
what you just piped and that will help
you get like a really round
perfectly shaped cream and then we bake
so once
you put these in the oven magic will
happen they should puff up into these
cute little
round balls of love
just in time for valentine's day
seriously though you don't have to make
this on valentine's day you can make
this whenever you want
not that i like ever do anything for
valentine's day
not bitter or anything if you want to
take me out for valentine's day
subscribe to my youtube channel
and now the fun part we're going to fill
these little
cream puff puffs with our delicious
strawberry custard filling you're going
to want to make sure your custard is
completely cooled down before you
pipe it so first you're just gonna poke
a little bit of a hole in the bottom of
the cream puffs shell
and then we're gonna take this even
further
and dip the tops of these cream puffs
in some melted chocolate so that they
get their
chocolate strawberry shell
i'm the puff daddy of cream puffs i'm
the puff mama
like puff daddy but like puff mama
i'm puff mommy
okay who wants to take me on a date
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you